he threw up in the front row during one
of them really yeah one
up she tried to sneak and throw up she
was like
just you just rolled down her shirt dude
just call her out holy [ __ ] that lady's
throwing up
so then for the next 15 and this was
probably five no this is ten minutes in
so right away
right when i got on probably about five
minutes in her and her boyfriend in the
front row get up
and he he looks at me they stand up
right when i start and he's like
she's wasted right did this i was like
cool yeah and then she walked straight
back
into a wall like directly and there were
there was no mirror on this
jesus it's just a wall and
then they went outside and everybody you
know we all laughed and then they came
back in
about five minutes later and everyone
was like how the [ __ ] are you
standing and he was like gave her some
weed yeah and i was like
that's crazy yeah she's gonna be sick
one minute later was just like
but she was drinking sangria so it was
just oh it was just purple
just rolled out of her and then what do
you do and then for 15 minutes they were
cleaning up throw up in the front row
while you were just [ __ ] doing jokes
about cody's like how about politics
uh politics are coming that sounds like
a vinnie brand mess it was
yeah he's got hearing aids and he
screams the whole time
yeah did he go on stage no no he wasn't
he wasn't that mine we love vinnie
brandies
we [ __ ] we [ __ ] with him he's just i
was doing vinnie bran i was doing vinnie
brand's
stress factory in the beginning of
august and every promo was just about
like
vinnie if you hear this please don't
come and he yeah
and he puts his name on everything yeah
and he spells his name v-i-n-n-i-e it's
like what are you an idiot
it's v-i-n-n-y yeah he's like if trump
was a
thousand heir right he just puts his
name on
like restaurants and [ __ ] no one cares
[Music]